good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
fellow councillors
please remain upstanding for the council
prayer
almighty god grant to us all guidance
wisdom and judgment as we face the tasks
before us
and enable us now and always worthily
to destroy the starch the sacred trust
placed by the people in our heads
thank you councils just a change of
format before the mayor starts with the
uh
public council meeting for those who
haven't already heard we just got a
slightly different format today
and that's because there isn't interest
in the pvp
public part of the meeting which
darren's going to run later
because it involves the museum
governance group
project and so we're going to do the
public
council meeting followed by the public
pe meeting
and then we're going to triple p meeting
and then we go into the public excluded
triple p meeting and at the very last
one we'll come back to the council
public exclude so we're doing the two
open ones to start with the two close
ones to start with
and at the end of the last one these
worship will draw
from the last item which involves his
legal case with the city council
thank you for that that's all you need
uh apologies anyone
being mad uh public forum
nothing there
and i think um
we have a declaration of interest isn't
part of the agenda anymore is that right
no it's just updated it's been updated
okay that's just there on the agenda as
a remote
reminder to councillors
of the change there
minutes of the meeting of council held
on the 28th
of may 21
20
25th may your worship thank you 25th of
may
2021 your worship before they are moved
i would just point out that there was an
amen or not an amendment but a change to
the minutes circulated to councillors
and you can see it on the screen in
front of you um
i'm councillor sober happy to move with
the amendment
moved and seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye aye aye
it's carried minutes of the meeting
we moved down to there and it's of the
meeting of the infrastructural services
committee held on the 1st of june
2021 i will move those you worship
moved and seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
against
carried minutes of the meeting of
performance policy partnerships
committee held on the 20
on on the 8th of june 2021
move they received your worship in it
see can they be received i'll put it to
the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carrie minutes of the
meeting of the bluff community board
held on the 14th of june
i'll move that those up
minutes of the bluff community board
held on the 14th
of june 2021
sorry that your worship very received
what a move in a second
we've got
minutes of the meeting of the riskin
assurance
committee held on the 21st of june 2021
uh i'll move that they'll be received
tuition second
thank you question
question of the chairman there's a
recommendation to council should that
be included
yes that's a recommendation to council
can anyone help us with that mr mia they
can be moved as part of
the seat of the minutes or they could be
moved separately at this stage the
minutes it has been moved that the
minutes be received
and only that so i'm assuming that those
two recommendations will be moved
separately after the minutes of being
received or i could include
uh the adopting of recommendations as
well and
uh receiving that okay yeah thank you
for pointing that out all right have we
got a mover and seconder for that
yes council upon you and myself
thank you i'll put it to the vote all in
favor say aye
aye
here to present her thank you
the adoption of the long-term plan
and we'll be council officer will
move there
or present the report
welcome to the meeting rihanna thank you
your worship
kia ora councillors um so yes i will
take
this report as read for the adoption of
the long term
plan our roadmap to renewal
i just want to take this moment to thank
you all for the direction and guidance
that you've given
through this process in terms of
developing the long-term plan
and to thank all the other members of
the staff who've actually made this
happen
i know it's been me at workshops
giving you lots of information and being
the face
at meetings for reports but this is
actually a
joint effort that has been contributed
to over the last 18 months by
many people um i think that the plan
that you've arrived at for the community
is a good strong plan outlines your
roadmap to renewal
so this report now is the final formal
part of the process
to present the plan to present the audit
opinion that has been provided by audit
new zealand
along with the letter of representation
and it just notes those final elements
the financial strategy the
infrastructure strategy the revenue and
finance policy and the rating policy
which are adopted alongside and as part
of the long-term plan
thank you your worship questions yes
thank you um i'm happy to move the four
recommendations
and and echo the the sentiments of
rhiannon in
our gratitude to the staff for the
amount of time
uh that they've put into it from a
council law
perspective across all of the long-term
plans that we've been through it's the
most engaged i've seen
councillors we've had really good
engagement with members of the public
we got to the point where everybody was
actually comfortably deliberating having
gone through the hearings process for
which we received some really good
feedback
where we um made the decisions in
in public as well so this
is as i say the most engaged and the
most transparent long-term plan that
we've gone through
so it's with uh with a great deal of
pride that i'm happy to move those full
recommendations sir
i'd be very happy to second them on the
same principles your worship
congratulations to the staff
thank you
councillor sopher i thank you your
worship i was indicating i was going to
second but councillor lewis
has seconded i just wanted to also say
i think it's an ambitious and very
robust long-term plan
um and echo the thanks to the staff who
put an enormous amount of time
and energy into making sure that it was
both
robust we councillors i suppose
claim the ambition but the robustness
thank you to the staff who
really put in the effort to make sure
that we had all the background
that we had a thorough consultation and
very thorough discussion
so thank you thank you councillor clark
yes you worship i'd prefer those four
recommendations i dealt with
individually
because i have some opposition to
recommendation three
yes i think that can be done
um i guess i just like to echo the
sentiments that everyone else has
already um
mentioned this is my third long-term
plan and it certainly feels like
the most engaged this council has ever
been in a strategic planning process
and when i think back to the very start
of this process
and the mountain of uh work we had to
all sift through
um in order to get to this place i think
uh that everyone's done a really good
job
um of of being strategic uh in the way
that we've been thinking about
this in a way that we've uh addressed
the information
and the issues and the projects that
we've had and i'm really excited that
we've got a road map
and that it's something that we can use
in the future um that we can measure our
progress against that we can use to show
the public how we're going
on things and how we can when we go back
to this process again in three years
time
show the public where we're making a
change of direction
if that's necessary or where we've gone
in a different
way so thanks also to everyone for their
really hard work
thank you councillor thank you worship
uh like i'd like to follow the same
sentiment as councillor sober saying
that
it's ambitious but um
the key thing is with the timeline
presented
in this long-term plan it is achievable
and that's the key thing it is
achievable we've set
we've set a guideline on how we're going
to do things
where the money is to be spent and a lot
of
common sense has been applied to this
and i totally support it
yeah thank you worship um and i have the
same sentiment as my colleagues but i
have a sticking point that i've declared
um repeatedly on the issue of the museum
and so i just wanted to clear that up
front i accept that the long-term plan
needs to be approved or not approved
today
because of these other issues that sit
around the long-term plan but i just
want to express my
opposition based on the fact that we
have not listened to the public in
relation to the
museum project quite clear that the
museum's been closed for three years
been close for three years and if i'm
honest we've done little or nothing in
that time
if you read the notes that are about to
come up in the pvp meeting in fact we've
done little or nothing around the museum
for the best part of a decade
and so we're now stuck with a museum
that's closed so
we've had three sets of significant
community engagements
since august last year so we had a
professional survey done some research
done which clearly showed that the
museum was the top priority
for the public to get resolved we did
our own public
project prioritization engagement which
again reinforced the museum
and lastly we did the long-term public
consultation process
which also reinforced the importance
around the timing of the museum
so for me it's not the overall package
it's just how long it's going to take to
resolve this issue
i find it interesting that last year we
received a paper
very late last year from an engineering
quantity survey report from the chief
executive
and it said that the cost of the museum
was 52 million odd
but it also importantly said that this
project was a 37-month project so that's
three years
and i still struggle why we need six
years to get this delivered
and it's like it's time for our council
to be brave and upfront
when i look back at the last long-term
plan and i wasn't on council at the time
i note that in the front end of that
there are five
sorry six projects one of them has been
delivered and that's the
hydro slide the other five have not even
been started
and so that doesn't fill me with
confidence going forward and i guess the
challenge for everybody around the table
me included is to make sure that staff
are not blamed for the lack of delivery
it's the fact that councillors haven't
held the staff accountable
for deliveries projects and this
long-term plan and my view won't be
worth the papers written on
unless we ensure deliverability so i
just want to express that
thank you thank you
anyone else wish to speak to the subject
counselor partinger um in reply to what
counselor clark has said i would
totally disagree and and the fact that
the feedback i've had
is that people are after a quality
museum
in the such such a way that our stadium
is unique in new zealand
they want a museum that that goes into
the future
for generations that will excite people
educate people to throw
money away in haste to achieve something
because it hasn't happened is can i
speak
please can i speak
you worship can i speak without
interruption
well nothing can be guaranteed but okay
right
right so i mean there is the option of
doing things in haste
and potentially throwing away 40
40 odd million dollars and what do you
achieve you achieve a replica of what
we've had before
sorry i'm after something that was much
much better than that i think we can
achieve the stadium is
again is the example of what we can
achieve
and the what we're going to see later in
the committee
papers is how we're going to achieve it
with
a committee or a group advisory group
that are going to deliver
us something to consider councillor
edmondson
thanks your worship um i totally endorse
what councillor pottinger has
um said and would also go as far as to
say it's
slightly misleading to say that we've
been doing nothing for three years
uh this southland museum and art gallery
and invercargill
public art gallery have worked really
hard to create hawakituya
which is filling a gap
i acknowledge it is not a big museum it
is not a
fancy museum but it is what we have
and it is filling a gap for this interim
period
and you know there's lots of plans ahead
for
doing lots more things there and for it
to become something and that's
integral part of our inner city i'd also
just like to mention that comparing the
2006
19 18 2018 ltp
and the 2021 ltp is definitely not
comparing apples with apples
we've already talked a lot about how
this long-term plan is
actually a strategic document and i
don't know whether that can be said
um to the same extent in previous ltps
that this council has done and so i've
got a lot of faith that this council
has developed something that is
achievable
and to do anything quicker as councillor
pottinger said
would be a disservice to the museum it
would be a disservice to the arts
culture and heritage sector
in our community and it would be a
disservice to this council
thank you worship um following along
a similar line i guess one of the big
changes that's happened between the 2018
ltp and this one is the ownership of the
project has shifted
with the clarification of the ownership
of the building and that it actually
belongs to the invical city council
rather than
as a southland museum and art gallery
owned
facility and and that clarity has come
through with with a great deal of
research over the past three years so
who owns the project
has shifted the project then as a city
one
fits in with as a
roadmap to renewal points out a
significant number of really
weighty projects um you know the level
of
capital expenditure that this council is
looking at over the next couple of years
is a couple hundred percent above where
we've been
in the past it's significantly higher
and we've got uh in in recommendation
too
that that opinion from the
uh the auditor that points out and we've
already acknowledged
the complexity of the project and the
concern around
deliverability and the age where
many projects are underway there is a
lack of
surety in some areas around the
availability
of workforce or capacity of of
contractors
supply of materials
um and even the ability to get out and
work if there's another
lockdown fius and and i hope councillor
skel
forgives me but if i use the rebuild of
ilt stadium south and as an example
they were very aspirational in what they
sought
to achieve but in the interests of
making sure they got it right
they ended up having to push out beyond
the timeline that they said that they
were going to finish it
now we could sit here and and change the
date that we want to see things finished
by
and hope that some form of magic is
going to make that happen
i would rather set a more realistic date
for completion
and have the pleasure of going we've
been able to finish early
if that can in fact happen rather than
to be in a position where we end up um
disappointing uh people who were raising
their expectations above
deliverability and i come back again to
that caution that's been given to us by
the auditor
and by our staff repeatedly so
from that perspective i'm interested in
seeing things remain
as they are and it is key that
everything around the ltp is adopted
today because
otherwise there's a good chance we go
back and start again
and we continue to rate based on
the current rates which is going to end
up costing people
in council more there is and i have
explained
previously the op the opportunity to
look
at a variation to the long term plan
when we've got a chance to consider and
what's coming up
in uh ppp after this is a process that's
aimed at
getting us as quickly as possible
the correct information in a balanced
way that means that council's in a
position
um towards the end of this year the
beginning of next year to be able to
to make a really good informed
realistic decision it could be that that
report comes back and says
that it may be able to complete
a project sooner but we don't know
until we get that information i
understand the aspirations that
counselor clark has and and we've all
heard the feedback
about the desirability to have the
museum reopened
we've heard that from the day that we
decided to close the doors
but when we reopen them we want to make
sure that we've got it right
and we want to make sure that we've got
it on time we know that we want to have
something that people are really pleased
proud and excited with when the doors
are open
we don't want to have to go back in
afterwards
and fix things later counselors
thank you your worship councillors um
it's referring to what councillor park
mentioned about the museum
it's been closed now for over three
years and
really nothing has happened it's just
been a lot of talk
i had a conversation with a group
of young primary school children the
other day
not one of them have visited
our museum as a school group
three of them asked me what the museum
was all about
they said they've been to museums in
bluff and riverton
and other regions of new zealand look
it's a part of their education
and they as primary school children will
not be able
to visit our museum as a group
i care i just hope other people around
this table care
the way things are going there could be
another generation of primary school
children that may miss out
but we need action straight away your
worship no mucking around no go
on no
going around in circles in circles like
it has been for the last 20 months that
i've been on council
thank you thank you i'm
aware that we transgress standing orders
where you're only meant to speak
once but i'm not i'm notorious for every
debate is um really robust
of living letting people have their say
more than once but i think it's getting
close to that time
it's for anyone who feels they've
something to add to the debate
instead of sober thank you your worship
i'm not going to repeat anything that
others have
said i'm just going to say that for me
it comes down to
do we want what we've always had on this
issue
or do we want something that we'll be
proud to leave to the future
if that means taking a little bit more
time to get it right
and open something that we're actually
proud to leave now
both for now and for the future i think
that we have put an
enormous amount of time and effort into
setting up hey wakatuya
which has been taking school groups and
i think that that will continue to
fulfill that function
and give our young people the idea that
councillor keith has just referred to of
what a museum is about
and there are other very good museums in
our local area that will do the same
and we should encourage that those
museums are also used because we are
part of a region so for me it comes down
to
exactly what do we want if we want what
we've always had
then we will make a hasty decision that
we will regret
and that our successes on this council
will regret in the future and it will
cost more money
taking a little bit more time to get it
right and to deliver something that is
exciting that is new
and that is relevant both for the past
that we're displaying
and for the future that we hope to be
part of that
museum is something that i think is very
important to do
we have the expertise to take advantage
of and we should take advantage of it
now
thank you unless anyone's got a burning
desire to speak i'll put it to the boat
where did these appear in the report
okay on your screen is item one
two three and four and
chancellor clark has indicated
do what i prefer to them to be voted on
independently
i think considering the considering the
importance of this issue
i think we need the formalities here and
councilor clark needs to
move for it to be taken in part because
it has been moved as a whole
as the mover um and and to give
councillor clark his right to vote a
certain way i have no issue with the
items being taken
separately in the secondary worship i'm
quite in faith i'm not in favor so much
but
quite an agreement that occurs
thank you thank you put it to the vote
then item one received the report and
adoption of the 2021
20 31 long term plan
all in favor say hi
again
note the audit new zealand letter of
representation
and opinion which has been received
by the risk and audit assurance
committee on the 21st of june
2021. sent to the vote all in favor say
aye
aye adopt a long-term plan
including the following strategies
and policies which are contained within
the
financial strategy the infrastructural
strategy
the revenue and finance policy and the
rating policy
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
hi
again i am opposed to worship and like
it recorded
thank you be noted in the minutes
and four delegate to the general manager
for
finance and assurance responsibility to
make corrections
to minor errors and emissions within the
long-term plan
fees and charges schedule
and supplementary materials as required
all in favor say aye aye against
carried the worship that brings us to
the second part of the process having
uh gone and adopted the long-term plan
which is the resolution
to set the rates there are four
recommendations
that sits as a part of tab nine
that we received the report resolution
to set rates and having set out the
information on the funding impact
statement and rating and revenue and
financing policies
you can read the rest uh across on
page uh
306 is the third resolution resolving
that rates will be payable and four
equal installments on the dates as
listed
and on 307 results to where the
following penalties as listed in a b and
c
unmoving them moved and seconded
discussion
questions
in the standard format and um puts into
effect what you've just agreed in the
long term
you need to move her in second amendment
councillor ludlow and a secondary
it's been moved and seconded i'll put it
to the vote all in favor say
aye my ends carried
can i just on behalf of the
excuse me the committee that's been
looking after
the program for working on working
together on tab 10
is the report to the council
with a range of six recommendations i
just note
in terms of the report that the
30th of june will show in terms of the
financial implication of the
program post the thompson review will be
under budget
for this year and the budget has been
set as approved
now at 420 000 for
2021 22.
the working groups are back operating
you'll see the
list of the working groups in the first
tab
appendix a i just draw the attention to
counselors that we reduce the number of
working groups from
five to four and collapse two into
what's now known as support for
councillors and since the report was
written
uh that group has working group has met
and councillor soper was appointed as
the chair
and council of cricket as the deputy so
all of the groups are now
up and running again post the ltp
uh should also note there is a
recommendation
in regard to the six monthly review
plus the thompson review so it was
proposed as part of the original
resolutions passed by the council
and setting up working for working
together that
there would be a review of the 30th of
june this year and another one in
december
risk and audit has approved and
recommended to the council
the setting out of that review which
would take place
starting next week if approved by
council and on the basis of that would
report back to
council in july uh seeing what progress
is being done
for the first six months happy to answer
any questions
come to the clerk yes and similar to
with the long-term plan your worship
could these um
recommendations be done individually
because i know you've publicly stated
that you're opposed to
the recommendation for so i think it'd
be helpful to do them individually as
opposed to doing it in a block
not happy to to move them be dealt with
in the on an individual basis
so the six recommendations there you'll
have me to move those
is it block or um
i've moved them in worship on an
individual basis
so they'd be done six recommendations
the original pump happens to second
council clarkson
let's just speak to it no i don't wish
to speak to it i think it's
straightforward you wish
thank you thank you any further
questions discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
no it's carried i just need to backtrack
your week
sorry you're going to backtrack your
worship but there was a there was
the move and secreted um both put that
we'd deal with all
six individually not as a collector
so we'll just have to put each one
separately oh i thought it was the other
way around
okay definitely starting at the top then
item one
yes he's
received a report of working on working
together
update from the project governance
group so that gets put as item one does
it
is through a seconder for that
put it to the vote all in favor say
aye aye against kerry
notes of updated changes to the working
on working together framework
and i don't even need to put it to the
boat
yep single notes the impact of
consulting that has been engaged to
undertake a survey
to evaluate project progress
endorse the terms of reference what
point of order you worship
the the move and seconder ask
that each of the six be taken
individually so each of the six does
need a vote
absolutely the same mover and seconder
has moved each one
but they need to be voted on
individually
all right item two we put to the boat
all in favor say aye aye aye it's
carried
item three is the notes and that
impact consulting
has been engaged to undertake a survey
to evaluate project
progress or move
it's been moved
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye aye
against carriage endorse the terms of
reference
is it right put that to the vote item
four
all in favor say aye aye against
carriage
item 5 notes of the six months
review is scheduled for
consideration by council on the 27th of
july
2021
all in favor say aye aye gets carried
notes of the six months review
i've done that one
and number six the councillor's
professional development program
has begun with a financial governance
workshop
held on the 25th of may and the
scheduled workshop
gamer from a governance
perspective of the 30th of june
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye is carried
your worship just before you go to the
next item i wonder if i could make an
observation in case it
passes unnoticed and that is that
um the decisions that you took on the
ltp and the rates are
a significant ones in terms
of the working on working together
program you'll recall
councillors will recall that there was a
serious
question raised about the council's
ability to prioritize
projects and to make decisions and stick
to those decisions
today you have reached a significant
milestone
in adopting your ltp not only
as a reflection on the significant
amount of work that went in
but also as evidence i would have
thought to your community
that you do have the capability capacity
to fulfill
the expectations of you set out in the
thompson review
so i think it's a milestone um
in in a number of respects that um
i had a duty to acknowledge for you
so you want that put to the vote
formally
now it's not a matter of voting they're
moving on to your report you can
talk to the council about what you've
been up to yes
now we're about to start i said on the
screen or is it
now um
just uh on to the mayor's report now um
uh as representatives of the community
we often
have to get involved in tragic events
within our
region 42 years ago
25 people were killed on mount erebus
in 1974 which was more than the pike
river
mine and canterbury earthquake victims
combined
all the lights were left on at
invercargill airport
because the airport directors could not
believe that a plane had simply
disappeared
at a harrowing royal commission
justice man found that there had been an
orchestrated litany of lies
all we can learn from these disasters
like white island and pike river is
that um is that accidents
are likely to happen and we should
always be prepared for the worse
also listed uh
my engagements and comment on just a few
issues that i've attended
i'll put it to debate did it be received
all in favor say aye
thank you okay thank you for that let's
move to the secondary
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
it's carried
this meeting be adjourned councillor it
might be easier to move into public
excluded
and then adjourn okay just the
motion for it sure i'll move accordingly
second in second
put it to the back all in favor say aye
aye
it's carried and now if you return the
meeting
and now the meeting will return to
ebay
are you meeting
there are no apologies or items of
public forum that i'm aware of
uh we have two
major light i've late items um
one was listed as minor but the chief
executive has suggested that it's
actually probably more than minor
and those
are to be taken in
so the first one which has to do with
the dhb is in public
and the second in public excluded
so would somebody like to move that they
are received as major late items in
public and public excluded councillor
pottinger seconded
councillor lewis thank you
any questions if not i'll put that all
in favor against
carried which brings us to
the establishing of the governance group
for reimagining the invercargill museum
um let me preface
uh mr gibling's report with
the fact that
despite people holding different
opinions it is
reassuring that people feel so
passionately
about our museum and art gallery
um the step that council is looking
at now is not dissimilar to what
happened with with street
streetscapes but is certainly on
a much uh tighter timeline with it with
a far
greater workload and i'd like to think
that that probably reflects the
urgency with which we have clearly heard
that people want to see this proceed
with that steve i'll hand over to you to
present your report
thank you mr chair good afternoon your
worshiping councillors
take this report as read if i may just
add a few comments
so this is part of the ltpt
deliberations
council resolved to establish this
governance group
and this paper is enacting that decision
what we're proposing is that the role of
this group is to develop a unique and
compelling vision for the museum
that would define the nature of the
services for the community of
invercargill and solidify its role
within the southland region
in doing so and and establishing that
governance group
we've set out within this paper what we
believe the roles of the governance
group are
and the advice that they will provide
back to you
we've also identified within this paper
the skill sets
and the mix of skills required on that
group
which are also set out in this paper
this is a
a very complex project that we
understand the importance of this to the
community
and so we think this balance of skill
sets is the right skill set to get us
the advice to help us make this decision
in terms of establishing the governance
group we're proposing that you also
establish an appointments panel
and that you delegate the role of the
appointing the governance group to the
members of their appointments
panel and that that group will appoint
the five
at large positions and will make sure
that
they achieve that balance of skill sets
required to provide that advice
back to you we'd also
recommend that you invite the local
roonaka
to appoint an early representative
direct to that governance group
in terms of the time frames where
identifying that we will have a
preliminary report back by
december which will provide initial
advices
to the options of both location which
you've identified in your deliberations
as well as to whether or not the
current option remains the option that
is progressed or whether or not there is
a
another option that comes through and
that will be driven by
the clear vision that is set out for
this museum
i'm happy to take any questions thank
you councillor clark
yeah thank you um steve i've i've had
some
uh a range of questions here in relation
to
um part of the recommendation so if you
can help me with those i know i've put
them to you already and i'm
pleased that there's i guess some
movement on the
time frame which was initially february
coming back to december so it's really
helpful
and also that the group is looking to
the wider
issue of new versus um re-strengthen
museum
costs and time frames for the project so
i'm really pleased with that
because that's the way forward but i do
have some specific questions so if you
can help me with those
you've already answered the first one
which was could could the or partly
answer the question is could the group
meet weekly and therefore report back in
four months as opposed to meeting
fortnightly
and reporting eight months later so i
guess you've answered that by saying
there's some work in that area yes uh
just i'd like to clarify that councillor
clark
that the preliminary report will be
provided before christmas
however that report might identify that
you then need to undertake consultation
through the annual plan process to make
an amendment to the long-term
plan so just want to clarify that yeah
understand that
um the second issue for me was um how
will
interested groups and i'll be one of
them i guess
give a viewpoint to the to the
governance group do i have a
views me an example do i have an ability
to um
do a report or physically front the
group and give my views
and other people that may be interested
may wish to do exactly the same
so is that is that an opportunity or is
this is this group going to be just
primarily driven by what paperwork has
put in front of them
and then go out looking for other
expertise thank you council that's a
good question
um look in terms of this this is one of
the benefits of having an independent
chair appointed
is that they will look at the range of
advice and
the discussion that has happened in the
community in quite an open transparent
manner
they'll be able to consider to what
degree other advice is provided or
sought from that
group and then that will be brought back
to the group to determine that so i
can't
preempt what the independent share will
do
but we're we're indicating in this
report that there is a range of
technical advice
that we believe they will need to
provide in order to give you
a clear decision both on vision and its
impact on design
what they choose to provide both in
their own research capacity as
as members of that group or through what
the independent chair asks us to find on
behalf of them
i think we'll leave that for the chair
to determine two other quick questions
which we've discussed before
one was the issue in the uh document
that was presented to us on the work
in the workshop was around the cost for
an ewe representative
and and i've suggested to you that that
should be kept at 15
000 because it was significantly more
than that i just wondered what your view
was on that
yeah um one other decisions that was
well i guess your deliberations we
identified a provisional
sixty thousand dollars for the advice
and we've then
worked with the project management
office to determine that the range of
technical advice and we're indicating
now
that the costs are slightly more
within that 60k though we
allocated honorarium for
both the independent share and also
recognition that there might be other
members requiring
honorarium to get them engaged
that is certainly well under
well within that budget and again until
we have run the process of finding the
members i can't
determine exactly what that number looks
like but we will be able to bring back a
report to you
uh identifying those costs i think that
would be helpful because the original
cost when there
will meant that the honorarium being
given to the ewe representative
was more than what i get as a deputy
mayor city
that uh that was within yeah yeah just
the last one and this may have gone by
the way by now but
part of the cost we had in that original
paper in a workshop also
included what was described as cultural
narrative
i'm not quite sure what that means
because it had a it had a figure about
35 000 sitting alongside it so
yeah and help me with that that would be
great yes as part of this
uh provisional sum we've allocated a
range of advice from
technical architectural in engineering
services mechanical uh we've also
included a provisional summon there for
cultural narrative now
once we've i guess once you've
adopted this governance group and the
structure for that
and we then will let that sit with the
chair and then we will come back with a
detail of how we have
uh what advice is coming back and
how much that will cost and so we've put
it just a provisional sum in there
uh we thought it'd be appropriate to put
it in now rather than
not put it in and ask for more later if
we needed it
and as a final reflection i noticed in
the original documents you had
um money put aside for um honorarium
and just wanted to give some personal
advice on it i think
we get into all kinds of tax issues if
we start giving individuals koha
to the volume what we're giving it
really needs to be an honorarium because
coho is tick free
no that's acknowledged thank you thank
you
councillor keit yeah thank you mr
chairman
can i ask a question uh having
establishing this group
why aren't councillors
involved appointment of councillors to
this group
any reason for that it is in the report
steve do you want to highlight the
answers written in there
yes uh thank you counselor um
[Music]
ultimately this group will be providing
you advice back
and that indication that that will be
towards the end or that'll be towards
end of the year
um i think the experience on
streetscapes is the role of the
councillor
and councillors on that group they by
default become spokespeople for the
group
which almost takes away the need for
what we're proposing as the independent
chair
so on the basis that council will be
receiving all the advice and counsellors
the decision maker in this we felt that
it was appropriate that we
tried to get the right balance of skills
and not
allocate roles uh to counsel when you're
getting the advice
ultimately anyway thank you uh just
other projects council have had over the
years mr chairman like the
the library they had councillors on that
group
uh the swimming pool
and the lunar swimming pool
and the civic theater the uh
multi-million dollar upgrade there
we had elected members from this
council appointed i think there was four
on each of those
different projects um
i i i can't see why like
we're elected members i think we should
have
some of us should have an input one
thing i'm against
is paying people to be on this group
if these people approach are approached
and are passionate
about their city i i believe they will
do this job for nothing
i believe it's a waste of 110 to 175
000 paying people
that's all i've got to say thank you so
in in response to that um
if if you want the best information
essentially these days you've got to pay
for it and you're looking for a lot of
expert advice
and and one of the things and trying to
make sure we can get the report back to
us
in as timely a manner as possible
bearing in mind that everybody wants us
underway as soon as we can
as there's going to be quite a workload
and that's going to impose on
on people's work time so you know
i think the justification for honorary
koha whatever you want to call it is is
justified
you make a valid point around council
law
appointees and and i guess one of the
the rationale there's
there's reasons for and against and i
guess one of the rationale of not having
counsellors involved in this bearing in
mind that ultimately we are the decision
makers is to try and de-politicize it
because there are so many different
viewpoints it could be if somebody
any one of us is appointed that somebody
else might feel that they're not
an adequate representative and it can
just it can get
in the way of the process um
if if we were having no involvement at
all if it wasn't coming back to us if we
were just
expected to to rub a stamp what it is
that's put in front of us without
putting back that
perspective that we're there on behalf
of the community to do
once we've got the report then i would
have concerns
but personally i think it's a it's a
good way of de-politicizing the process
that's that's my view however it's open
for
comment by any other councillors steve
do you have any feedback on
the first part uh no look probably just
to clarify
for the councillor as well that the
majority of the costs here are
is technical advice so it is paying for
engineering it is playing for
architectural
it is playing for a quantity surveyor
and the project management support
that's the majority of the cost so it's
all professional advice
councillor amundsen thanks um
my question is around i guess community
buy-in to this process and the outcome
of this
what is in place here to ensure that the
governance group is actually going to
come up with something that aligns with
um
community or that the community is
willing to buy into because i know
a lot of work uh using the streetscape
governance group as an example
a lot of work went into kind of working
together with the community to get
feedback and to develop that
we've already done a bunch of engagement
and consultation
already about museums and art galleries
and all those kinds of things so
i realize that's not a necessary part of
it
but i guess i'm wondering what's to stop
this governance group
when you know only one of those skills
is around
um arts culture and creativity etc
a lot of the other skills are more
around project
development and stuff like that how are
we going to make sure that that group
comes up with something that
is relevant and bought into by
the arts culture and heritage sector
yeah that's a i think you can so it's a
good question
the these skills that we proposed in the
report are not to be taken as one-offs
we're looking for a mix of skills and a
mix of experience and so
to some degree we're expecting that
everyone on that group will have some
degree of link to the arts culture
heritage education and museum sectors
and it's you know
the range of services that a museum a
modern service
provides is as much about science and
education as it is about arts culture
and so
for me that there is an element of we're
looking for that balance
we're also looking for the way in which
they can then
relate to and communicate to
stakeholders and
there is an element of also and you've
touched on it that
we're not short of reports and
consultation
and it's what this group does with it
and turns it into action both around the
service and the design element i think
that is critical
there will be regular reports back stick
back to council
from the independent share on progress
and i think there will be
um some process where we share the work
and what
where things are at by this group
councillor abbott then councillor
partner just a thought really
to um come up with what being said
excuse the voice
could there not be a terms of
appointment
communication in the appointment of
the independent chair would that help uh
sorry i'm not
fine to take in the community
involvement could that not be a
term of appointment there is a brief but
it's npa
short answer your question is yes yes
yeah counselor partner
thank you chair uh steve um i guess my
question is it's really asking you if
i've got the
right take on this is that this
governance group
will bring back the ideas to council in
december
and it's not them who are to communicate
with the public
but for us to take on board their their
ideas
they present to us we then formulate
our vision for the museum then we go to
the public
so the way it works i think that
ultimately that would be the way it
works because you're the ultimately the
decision makers on this
approach thanks
councillor lush yeah thanks chair um
look i like the report i like how it
looks like it's the right process to get
there are we happy with using the word
museum or is that being prescriptive and
describing something
before that's what they come up with and
i guess that's in light of the whole
visual arts and effect with
anderson's park and things like that no
longer been used
yeah that's a very good question i think
that's a great question that we'd
actually be asking
this group to consider look when you
look at
what modern museums do today
you are looking at something that is not
just about the history it is about
connecting our community
not only with culture but yeah
tonga science and education
um arts you know it is a bigger facility
than is just one word described and so i
think there's an element if we will see
this vision come out
we will understand what that vision
means for this service
and we will then understand how the
design of this new building
can be best reflected against that
vision okay yeah so it is a bit of a
working
title at the moment
i guess just as an addendum to that um
you know there are there are facilities
elsewhere that have taken on names that
do not
incorporate the word museum habakkuk for
example
um yeah yeah
so yeah yeah it's a good point
it may well not form part of the name
thank you any further questions
counselors
if not right we've moved to the
recommendations um
there are seven there should we have a
crack at moving them in a block or do we
want to take them individually
i would like to move them as a block as
a block
okay thank you it wasn't a
tongue-in-cheek i mean if
somebody wanted to thrash something out
on me i'm quite open to it
however it's been moved and seconded uh
one through to seven i'll put that
counselor's all in favor
aye against hi would you like your vote
recorded councillor kit
okay thank you that moves us
to the paper that you've got
from andrew cameron
around the southern district health
board dunedin hospital review
yes mr chair andrew is here if you would
like him to speak to it
but i think that counsellors could well
have had the opportunity to read it uh
if i could explain to you that the
reason for it coming to you today is
because the mayoral forum meets on
friday the 9th of july
this is an issue that is originating
here
as a result of our perusal of cabinet
papers
but really is a southland issue and
should be referred to
so there are two recommendations
councillors council sopra are you moving
or you know you'll be declaring
i am declaring or bringing to the
attention of council my
my declared interest that i am an
elected member of the
um southern district health board
however in this case
i do not see that as an
interest that prevents me from so it's
an interest not a conflict
exactly thank you bye councillor
i'm looking for a second secondly
councillor scout gave me the nike nod
council is open for discussion
if not i'll put the motion all in favor
aye against
carried counselors will now move into
public excluded for the two items as
outlined just a reminder to members of
the public
once we've concluded the pe part of
performance policy and partnerships that
we will then
reconvene the full council budgeters and
committee so
i'll move that we go into public
excluded for the reasons as outlined
and thank members of the public and the
priests for their attendance
uh of course we're excluding the
external advisors who are allowed to
remain with us
in that motion which i think is noted in
there sarah secondary
thank you councillor rabbit i'll put
that all in favor aye against
carried
you